we talked about how wonderfully quick it
is to use the mobile devices and that's
one of the things that's so terrific
about it but the camera in most of the
devices are not only low resolution
which is a problem but they're also very
wide-angle lenses so we have a lot of
distortion in most of the images when we
see it in a particular kind of image as
we're doing here when I quickly made
this image in our Provost's office in
fact I was very lucky that he wanted to
hang some of the pictures I made of his
work from years ago in his office and I
had about 30 seconds to make the image
showing the let's call it art at this
point on the walls and you see that the
image has problems it's distorted
because of the nature of the camera so
what I did was I selected the image and
then I went to image distort where I
then tried to undistorted I placed the
grid on top to help me figure out
actually exactly how much to move the
image and played around a little bit and
then I think I pretty much got it I went
to the cropping tool to make it as
symmetrical as possible and I think that
after these couple of manipulations we
can get a more straightforward image
just moving those things around a little
bit and just trying to make it a truly
symmetrical image which I think we did
here and I want you to just take a look
at the first image that I made and then
compare it to the more undistorted or
fixed image and this is what you can do
when you're looking at mobile devices
that really do distort the image which
is not what we want